hello again everybody and welcome to
another python 3 basics video in this
video we're going to be covering default
function parameters so i'm just going to
go ahead and clear this out
so normally we write a function like so
simple
and num1 num2
and that's it and then we have the
function do something for now i just
write pass that just gives it something
to do if i don't write anything here and
i define another function
it uh will be mad it will throw an error
it'll expects an indent
so anyway write something there but what
we can do
is something like this so to find simple
num1 and then we can do what's called a
default parameter num2 and by default we
just say num2 equals 5.
so what this is going to do
when you do this
is it's going to just by default give
num to the very uh the value of 5 so if
we print
num1
and m2
and then we call simple you actually
don't have to put anything in there we
could say five right even though we've
got two parameters
here
when you have a default it's
automatically filled so uh you don't
have to specify it so in fact let me
change this since we used five for
number two
and we'll run it
and sure enough we get two five so that
was fine we didn't throw an error even
though we only had one and that's
because this has some default uh
default value to it now why would
anybody use a default value
so an example of a
time when you might use default
a good thing to think about is say you
you're going to go buy a car and
maybe you care a lot about like what
kind of stereo the car has or whatnot
but you don't really care about the
types of tires that it has you're not
too worried about the suspension and all
that but then some people are worried
about the suspension and don't give
anything about the radio they just want
the stock radio in there and so on so
different people like to do different
forms of customization so an example of
this in programming would be maybe a
program that allows you to create
windows so basic window
and every window needs a width
and a height
um but then you have other things that
you might need in your window so what
are some things that you might need in a
window well you might need font so you
might need a font type and we'll do tnr
for times new roman
as a quick aside i'm going to have
i'm going to hit enter so you can what
you can do when you're specifying things
within parentheses is the following
comma enter and you can continue
specifying things here
and this can just kind of help
keep things a little bit more organized
so you don't run out of space or you
don't have like one really long line
okay
so some other properties that we might
want with this window
background color
by default let's say that's white
um
scroll bar
equals true and that'll do for now so
let's just say uh we have three
parameters here that
can be added
now in this basic window let's just say
we print
with height font bgc
and
um
we won't print scroll bar
anyway uh
and that's it so if we call basic window
the only thing that we really have to
specify here that doesn't have a value
already is width and height
so let's say we want it to be 500 pixels
wide 350 tall
okay so when we go to run this
we get 500 350 tnr w so we printed out
write all of the specifications here so
even though we didn't specify font bgc
scroll bar we were able to modify those
so then what happens if
you
uh do want to modify well generally what
you're going to see
is people type out the uh the name
but you could in theory do something
like this and we'll just say a for arial
and we run it and sure enough that
worked but the reason why people are
going to type it out
is because of the following what if you
don't care to change font but you want
to change background color well if you
don't want to type it out you're going
to have to type in a and then w because
obviously you throw a double eu in here
it's going to say the font type is w and
you don't want w because w is like
webdings and you don't want webdings so
obviously that would cause trouble so
what you're going to see when people
have default parameters is bgc equals
and then whatever they want it to equal
oops we lost our equal
save run and now you'll see
that tnr went unaffected but w
is there vgcw let's change it to
b for black
uh run it and you can see it we changed
it so obviously when we have this view
of variables like it's not that big of a
deal if you had to type them all out but
just imagine with some things people
like to make their modules really highly
customizable so like with matplotlib
you've got all kinds of things you've
got
line thickness line color
plot markers you've got
um
now i'm blanking there's a whole bunch
of stuff though that you can add and
with a lot of modules there's a whole
lot of stuff that they give you that you
can customize but at the same time
you're not forced to customize it if you
don't want to and they give you defaults
that make sense but if you want to
change it you could so anyway
that's just the basics
of default parameters and how to use
them and why they're used and all that
so hopefully you can recognize them and
if you wanted to add them to your own
program now you can
so uh that's it with this uh tutorial if
you guys have any questions feel free to
leave them below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support the
subscriptions until the next video